Traduttore: Cristina Mancuso
Revisore: Sofia Ramundo
Quello che abbiamo sentito
fino a questo momento
è stata l'esaltazione del genio,
di un eroismo della mente
e della creatività
che di solito noi leghiamo
all'individualità.
Il genio è sempre uno,
il genio è sempre unico
perché il modo in cui
è geniale è solo suo.
Quindi quello che io sto per dirvi
potrà sembrarvi un po' contro-narrativo
rispetto a quello
che abbiamo sentito fino adesso
perché Leonardo,
grande nume tutelare di questa assise,
è l'uomo che incarna, se vogliamo,
la sintesi di ogni genio del suo tempo
e anche del nostro, oserei dire,
perché geni così ne abbiamo visti pochi.
Io, invece, vorrei cominciare a riflettere
su un'inversione del paradigma,
diciamo così:
ragionare anziché sulla sintesi del genio,
sul genio della sintesi,
cioè come coordinare
la molteplicità delle creatività
di tante persone che hanno
visione, specialità, competenze
che, presi singolarmente, geni non sono
ma genialmente possono lavorare insieme.
Naturalmente parto,
per fare questo ragionamento,
dalla materia del mio mestiere,
che sono le storie.
Tutta la nostra vita
è costellata di storie:
da quando nasciamo
ci seguono fino a che campiamo.
Le storie occupano le librerie,
occupano gli schermi grandi e piccoli,
sin dall'infanzia.
Però non sono un materiale neutro:
noi ci abitiamo lì dentro.
Ma, per raccontare,
è necessario prima scegliere
cosa raccontare.
E il primo dato
che bisogna rilevare è che
la stragrande maggioranza delle storie
di cui noi siamo formati
sono storie di personaggi solitari.
Io ricordo la mia infanzia:
Pollicino abbandonato dalla famiglia,
nel bosco, che già lì è un trauma, no?
E deve tornare a casa
e lo fa con la mollica.
La fiaba omette il fatto
che a casa non lo vogliano
o lo abbiano, appunto,
abbandonato nel bosco.
Dolce Remì, che di famiglie
ne perde addirittura due,
vedo molti giovani presenti
che non sanno di cosa sto parlando,
questo mi fa sembrare
improvvisamente vecchia
ma mi consola il fatto
che vi sia stata risparmiata
la tragedia di Dolce Remì.
Pollyanna : povera orfanella
- simpatica eh, per carità -
però, anche lì, sola come un cane
che poi, la sua gentilezza
attira della simpatia intorno a lei,
ma parliamo sempre di una ragazzina
il cui principale dato di trama
è la solitudine.
Potrei citarvene altri ma ve li risparmio
perchè già mi sto intristendo.
Entro i sei anni, queste storie
erano già nel mio immaginario,
io che non avevo neanche la fortuna
di essere unica come figlia.
Mi ritrovavo, appunto, con mio fratello
e dovevamo dividerci
il tentativo di essere speciali
ciascuno a suo modo.
Tuttora io a volte lo chiamo
l'altro figlio di mia mamma
per sentirmi un po' speciale,
secondo quelli che erano
gli schemi della mia infanzia.
Crescendo, le cose non son migliorate:
io venivo da una famiglia cattolica,
quindi avevo anche le storie della Bibbia
a cui attingere.
Nelle storie della Bibbia c'è Mosè,
balbuziente ma tuttavia scelto da Dio.
L'unico che parla con Dio può guidare
il popolo di Israele alla Terra Promessa.
Poi c'è Davide: re pastore
che a tempo perso componeva anche salmi,
quindi anche qui siamo
sul genio multi-tasking.
C'è Sansone che combatte i Filistei
con una forza sovrumana
e li abbatte con, non si capisce perché,
una mascella d'asino.
Tutte queste figure,
si arriva poi fino a Gesù Cristo,
la specialità religiosa assoluta,
il più solitario dei solitari
che solo sulla croce, alla fine ci muore.
A quattordici anni
mi iscrivo al liceo Classico,
sì, lo so, sembra una vicenda
veramente tragica
ma in parte lo è.
Credo che collimi però con l'esperienza
dell'immaginario di tutti.
Al liceo Classico mi arriva addosso
tutta l'epica, per intero.
Achille, semidio,
indistruttibile, invincibile.
Se non fosse per quel piccolo particolare
che,comunque, nemmeno lui sa bene dov'è.
Agamennone, feroce guerriero
che arriva al punto di cinismo
di sacrificare la figlia
pur di procacciarsi un buon vento
che porti le sue navi fino a Troia.
E poi Ulisse, certo, il viaggiatore,
Dedalo, che sconfigge il Minotauro
dentro il labirinto.
Orfeo, l'investigatore degli inferi
che va per il suo amore
fino a dove vivono i morti.
In generale, sempre figure solitarie.
Se andavo al cinema
la cosa non cambiava eh!
Solo supereroi: Batman,
solo come Batman credo neanche Pollicino.
Superman,
cioè sempre drammi familiari alle spalle.
Fino a Luke Skywalker,
dentro il quale scorre potente la forza,
per arrivare a Harry Potter,
bambino magico, destinato a combattere
contro colui che non può essere nominato
e non lo nomineremo neanche qui.
Ecco, tutte queste storie
sono una sequenza di vicende
che corrispondono tutte
allo stesso schema:
figura solitaria,
che deve affrontare da solo tutto il mondo
o comunque un pericolo
davvero molto grande,
salva moltitudini in genere,
questo tipo di eroe
e lo fa in forza di un potere,
di una specialità
di una genialità che è tutta sua:
non fatevi ingannare dal fatto
che questi abbiano degli amici intorno.
Non sono storie corali:
se muore Ron Weasley,
la storia di Harry Potter continua.
Se muore Harry Potter,
della storia di Ron Weasley
non ce ne frega niente.
Quindi quando vi dicono:
"Ah, ma avevano degli amici"
si chiamano figure gregarie.
Quel tipo di schema lo ha già analizzato,
quando ha fatto, appunto,
le scansioni delle favola,
Propp: si chiama viaggio dell'eroe.
Quelle figure sono, appunto,
figure di supporto
che devono sostenere la missione dell'eroe
fino al compimento del suo obiettivo.
Ora, in mezzo a tutto questo,
io mi ricordo anche
della frase di Bertold Brecht che dice:
"beato il Paese
che non ha bisogno di eroi".
Ma come si fa a credere a questa frase
se le storie degli eroi ci connotano,
sono le prime che sentiamo da bambini,
le sole che studiamo da ragazzi,
e le uniche che ci ispirano da adulti?
Ci dicono che sono storie educative,
che servono a formarci il carattere,
ma esattamente a che cos'è che educano?
Io lo so. Lo so perchè lo vedo,
vedo di cosa è fatta la nostra società
costruita sulla base
di molte storie solitarie.
L'X Factor,
l'idea che tutto quello che si trova
di ben fatto al mondo
sia dovuto all'eccellenza
di singoli speciali,
e tutti noi che speciali non siamo,
benché avremmo voluto esserlo,
non siamo riusciti
a ottenere lo stesso risultato,
possiamo solo ammirarlo.
Ecco, le storie dell'eroe
studiate in questo modo,
sono storie ammirevoli,
ma non sono storie imitabili.
Ecco, io penso che questa cosa
non sia vera
ma non è vera proprio nella storia,
ma neanche nell'epica è vera.
La presa di Troia:
se ci si fosse dovuti fidare
dell'invincibilità di Achille
e della spietatezza di Agamennone,
quei due cretini sarebbero ancora
ciascuno nella sua tenda
odiando l'altro perché ha dovuto
rinunciare alla sua schiava
per l'orgoglio dell'altro eroe.
Quei due che litigarono, appunto,
per la questione Briseide e Criseide,
Troia non l'avrebbero presa mai!
C'è voluto Ulisse,
che ha avuto un'idea geniale e ha detto:
forse, se ci mettiamo insieme,
e facciamo una cosa che faccia,
appunto, la sintesi delle nostre genialità
e anche delle nostre cretinerie
in modo che un po' si stemperi
per il principio
delle cretinerie comunicanti,
anche il genio è comunicativo
ma anche un po' la scemenza lo è.
E dice: il cavallo di troia è questo,
il cavallo di Troia fa cadere
l'invincibile Troia
e quella vittoria è di tutti
proprio perché nessuno,
nessun eroe di quelli lì presenti
può dire "è mia".
E purtroppo, l'epica così
non ce la raccontano.
Ho visto che c'è una mostra
in questo momento,
mentre venivo c'era un cartello,
sembrava messo lì
tipo Candid Camera che dice:
"Ercole e le sue fatiche
nella storia dell'arte,
tutti quadri solo dell'eroe".
Ecco, le storie collettive
non ce le racconta nessuno.
Eppure è pieno, siamo circondati,
pensate a Wikipedia.
Quanti di voi qui
hanno scritto una voce di Wikipedia?
(Risate)
Qualcuno c'è, qualcuno c'è!
Tra i presenti, ecco, qualcuno c'è.
Wikipedia è una storia collettiva,
non ci ricordiamo magari i fondatori,
sappiamo che è un'opera
che richiede e ottiene il contributo
di milioni di persone nel mondo,
un sapere condiviso.
Penso a Messico '68,
quei due corridori assieme al bianco,
che li supporta con un gesto tutto suo,
che nel tempo di un inno nazionale
col pugno alzato in alto,
portano nelle case di tutto il mondo
il tema della discriminazione razziale.
Penso alla macchina di Turing,
allo sforzo di molti cervelli insieme,
dagli scacchisti ai matematici,
che riescono a decifrare
il codice dei nazisti,
e a far fare un salto di qualità
enorme alla guerra
che in quel momento forse senza di loro
sarebbe stata persa.
Queste storie non vengono raccontate.
La prima volta che io ho incontrato
una storia che mi ha cambiata
è stato quando ho conosciuto
"I ragazzi della via Pal"
di Ferenc Molnár.
Gruppi di ragazzi che si incontrano
per il controllo di un quartiere.
Certo, poi Nemecek muore,
è stato il primo lutto della mia vita,
ma anche lì
c'era qualcosa che non tornava:
erano tutti maschi,
e ripetevano lo schema della guerra
per il controllo di un territorio.
Quel modello di potere
è il modello che passano quelle storie,
è un modello sottrattivo,
dove se tu lo possiedi
è perché l'hai rubato a qualcun altro,
e quel qualcun altro,
come diceva Talleyrand, si logora.
La seconda volta
che ho visto una storia collettiva
però, è cambiato tutto.
A sedici anni ho letto "IT"
di Stephen King.
E "IT" di Stephen King
è una storia collettiva
dove non c'è dubbio
che tutti i protagonisti
siano assolutamente sfigati:
c'è un ciccione bullizzato,
c'è un balbuziente,
c'è un nero in un mondo di bianchi,
c'è un secchione,
c'è un ipocondriaco mammone,
c'è una femmina,
una di quelle che nelle storie dell'eroe
vanno salvate,
di sicuro non salvano.
Tutti loro sarebbero morti
in quella storia,
ma mettendosi insieme
ammazzano IT.
Ecco, dopo IT io vado in giro
a raccontare ai ragazzini
solo storie collettive,
perché non credano di poter essere potenti
solo uno contro l'altro,
ma imparino anche
che si può essere potenti insieme.
Perché, alla fine, la tempesta
è solo un milione di gocce d'acqua,
ma col giusto vento.
(Applausi e acclamazioni)
Ecco, voi siete tempesta,
senza dubbio.
(Applausi)
Grazie.